I've kind of gotten myself into a
predicament with um bills that are owed
and my shovel is not nearly big enough
and I feel like I'm running myself into
the ground trying to do side hustles and
after I signed my apartment lease I
found out that I was pregnant so I'm six
months into that Journey now and I have
bitten off way more than I can chew as
far as what I can afford okay what does
your husband M um I'm not married oh
where is the father in the picture um
finan Al not um he is excited about the
baby and all that good stuff but
financially not contributing at all I
guess I'll just start there uh he he
really doesn't have that option morally
or legally um if you father a child in
the United States of America you get to
pay child support it's how that works so
sorry Bubba you going to uh you get to
step up and uh participate in the
financial side of the equation